hello everybody markiplier here and I
just wanted to make a quick via on about
the fact that we have over 18,000
subscribers and I tried to wrap my head
around what 18,000 people even meant and
I found out that you could fill Madison
Square Garden with 18,000 people the
Roman Colosseum seated 18,000 people
every day 18,000 people is a is is
incredible it's an absolutely
astonishing number to have and I have
nothing but gratitude towards everyone
who feels that I'm worthy of a
subscription and I know that a lot of
gaming channels aren't lucky enough to
have what I have and I I still haven't
lost sight of the fact and I'm still
amazed every day and I started to look
back and I said yeah you all know my
goal of having a hundred thousand
subscribers by June and I can't even
wrap my head around seeing a hundred
thousand people in one place at one time
let alone 18,000 I mean it's one of my
favorite pictures of all time is this
old I'm not sure what era it is but it's
got to be pretty damn old but it's where
18,000 soldiers line up to form the
Statue of Liberty and it's it's just a
breathtaking picture because at first
glance it's like oh it's just a Statue
of Liberty but then you look like beyond
it and it's just more and more more more
people in this picture it's insane I
don't know if it's like photoshopped or
something yeah it might be it might not
be I don't know it might be a fake I'd
like to think that it's real because if
that's 18,000 people that's absolutely
incredible so anyway I just wanted to
make a quick video to thank you all for
getting to this point because it's a big
milestone and I don't want to like
dismiss the fact that getting another
thousand people isn't a big deal because
it is it absolutely is getting every day
I get about 300 or 400 subscribers and
it's I I don't lose sight of the fact
that that's a lot of people and I
remember back when I
when I was first starting I'd get maybe
10 new subscribers in a day and I'd be
like 10 10 that's amazing and now I mean
I my numbers in is's another thousand oh
my and I I want you all to realize how
grateful I am of that every day and I I
mean it'd be excessive if I made a new
video every day like we got another
hundred and then it kinda out of control
but that's how I feel you know that's
how I feel every day that's when I wake
up I jump out of bed on a mugger oh boy
how many do I have today
woah and you know it's just it's an
exciting feeling and I wish I could like
shove my excitement in your face and I
I can't just constantly make V logs like
this but I am more than excited about
everything that's going on in the
channel but that's all you know
excessive and I don't need to bore you
with that I'm just I'm happy that you
guys are happy and you guys like my
videos and you guys feel the need to
share my videos so let's just keep this
momentum going let's keep it going until
we hit a hundred thousand then plow past
that and hit a million and then plow
past that and go to some other
unrealistically huge number million I
can't even think about that right now
that's that's absolutely incredible but
thank you guys it's you guys helping out
you guys sharing my videos that's really
that's really what it's all about I mean
if you like every single person that
comes in new there's a certain person
that percentage that would share my
videos and that's what helps me grow
getting the message out to new people
that's what it's all about but that's
beside the point
my point of this whole v-log was
tomorrow is the first of many amnesia
custom story live streams and I've
decided that instead of just one unless
it's like a long one but instead of just
one I'm gonna use live streaming too and
these are custom stories and I'm not
just gonna be scraping the bottom of the
barrel in terms of quality goes I'm
actually going to be I will I've made a
rule I'm not going to do any amnesia
custom story on the live stream that's
lo 8.5 I'm not gonna do it it's just
it's it's not worth just doing a crappy
one and there there are quite a few so
we got plenty in store but I'm going to
do two and these are custom stories
tomorrow and they're gonna be good ones
I don't know if they're gonna be good
ones but they're rated highly so I hope
they're gonna be good ones so anyway man
just thank you guys so much for helping
out and you guys keep keep at it keep
the momentum up keep sharing the videos
pick out one of my reaction compilations
and please share it on Facebook on
Twitter do whatever you can to get the
message out because we are on a roll and
I never ever ever ever ever ever want to
stop not for as long as I live I am
never gonna stop so thank you all so
much please keep sharing and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye